tu fais là toi bah qu'est ce que je fais
je suis une émission de télévision qui
s'appelle autant en emporte le temps
deux milliards dans ce journal quand
même non mathieu pas venir qui est
ordonné une émission quand même ordonné
une émission ils ont aimé l'idée des
invités du présent du passé du futur
hors du temps ils m'ordonnaient assez
mangé vais penser à ce truc là il
fallait la déposer mon gars oui il ya un
truc que je comprendrai jamais avec toi
tu pourrais faire des émissions
vachement sympa mais qu'est ce que tu
t'emmerdes à faire ça vous ne suivrez
une émission tu prendrais des vedettes
qui chante
des braves gens qui racontent leur vie
un grand orchestre en direct
des millions à gagner qu'est ce tu
t'emmerdes c'est con quoi
[ __ ] ça va vos conneries là la philo
sur la télé ça pas comme ça je veux dire
d'accord 1 on l'a fait cette émission
c'est comme ça vole à une heure de ok ça
va ça va ça alors là fait cela
on s'énerve pas on l'a fait à les
appeler au public
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu